hello my name is sofia rosinski and i am
mac on paper girls i'm cameron jones and
i play tiff on paper girls what's up i'm
riley lineley and i play aaron on paper
girls
i'm phoenix graza and i play kj and we
are the cast of paper girls here with
buzzfeed to play a game of who's who
[Music]
cameron
they have the same attitude yes
the same same organization yes
and they
she's so nice and mac is abrasive
sometimes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't want to interact with your
future self but i feel like you'd
interact with somebody who knows your
future self and then that would mess up
the timeline i don't know
why i don't think so
time travel is a complicated thing and
any any one of us can best something yes
or riley riley or sophia one of them too
yeah for sure they're the 80s riley
would be like music she knows everything
yeah not everything everybody just knows
that i don't know everything
let's just say generally a lot of new
wave and i know that like the punk scene
was getting really popular
started to get popular in the 80s so any
like girls rock bands
[Music]
cameron cameron loves the you know
sci-fi theme
yeah i think i actually did read a comic
book on set one time i'm sure
her nose is always in a book
i would say sophia okay there's this one
time where we were filmed we were
filming and
it's written as mac looks intrigued and
i'm looking at her and sophia
sophia gives me like this smolder like
and i was trying to contain my laugh so
much i looked like this the whole time
i'm saying riley because there was this
one team and we were in a bed and i had
to whisper in kj oh and i'm like hey kj
and she's shaking the bed because we're
all in bed together
that is shameful
you guys would be like okay you guys
yeah i actually did do escape look at
that do your mystery face you have the
perfect like
do the eyebrow thing
see it's getting stronger that face is
going to solve a mystery
camera yeah
yeah or just random photos yeah without
context that's fair
or all of us together yeah
we would go all together we would make
trips in between
the crafty what was everybody's favorite
thing at crafty
i had these good apple crunchy things
oh i forgot about that yeah i love that
too the rice crispy apple crunch
the apple crunchy thing and chocolate
milk
we all have a lot of energy yeah so i
feel like none of us
right
[Laughter]
i'd say
huh i i
i don't know i feel like finn is very
wise it's because she's like the oldest
one so i would always go to her for
advice she is much she's very old
i say sophia she just she just has this
wiseness about her if you know what i
mean she talks in like riddles sometimes
but it's always very insightful what is
two hands
[Laughter]
[Music]
final
y'all too actually why then i did do
karaoke on set one time the translation
is true remember yeah yeah yeah i
remember that yeah they had a microphone
in our green room at the train station
and yeah we weren't really allowed to
talk to them but we did and
riley played some guitar um and we
serenaded everybody yeah
we also drink chocolate milk
thank you buzzfeed
make sure to watch paper girls on prime
video
you should watch it yeah
[Music]
you